(instrumental music)
- [Voiceover] Everyone always
has these grand aspirations about life.
When I grow up, I'm gonna do this.
Be this person.
I'm gonna make a name for myself.
I'm gonna be someone.
You know, always these big dreams.
I was the same.
I wanted that big job, that
big house, that fast car.
All of it.
Didn't get it, though.
Not even close.
I ended up here instead.
37 years at this place.
God, has it been that long?
First two years I told myself
it was gonna be a temporary thing.
I was gonna move on, get that big house.
It was only for the paycheck.
Supposed to help the
wife and feed the baby.
But then baby number two came and well,
two years turned into five
and five years turned into 10.
It's funny how things change.
How your perspective changes.
You grow up.
You get married and have kids.
You learn that a lot
of stuff they told you
when you were younger was just bullshit.
Life's always been about
lessons and moments.
That's all life is.
Just a series of moments.
Not things, not wants or even needs,
just simple, honest to God moments
that hopefully add up to you living
a decent life and being a good person.
Really, it's always been little moments
that you remember over
everything else anyways.
The smile of a loved one,
the sound of their voice in the morning.
How easy their hand fit into yours.
I didn't plan on ending up at this desk.
But it was where life took me.
I didn't get the dream.
I got a life instead.
And it was more than I
could've ever asked for.